I'm Justin this is Peter we are here
with a gamespot breakdown apparently
Facebook has just bought oculus and we
got off a call a press conference call
with Marco Zuckerberg explaining exactly
what that means I we didn't get a lot of
new answers we don't know a lot more
than we did with the the initial news uh
but is this something that we should be
worried about as you know as gamers as
people who are really excited for oculus
uh no i mean my initial reaction is that
this can only be good for oculus and in
turn good for us people tend to have you
know they attach this stigma to facebook
cuz they worried about privacy you know
facebook has bought in a few other
companies and they've served those
companies really well yeah they have
Instagram they have whatsapp and I use
both of those services and they don't
seem to have been affected negatively by
Facebook's purchase yeah and one of the
things mortgage like our burgers
mentioned is that he allows these
companies or facebook allows these
companies to operate independently still
there just owned and funded by facebook
at that point well do so do you think
that with this funding that that maybe
we'll see the retail project a retail
product come out a little bit sooner uh
no I don't necessarily believe that's
the case I think what oculus is always
stood for is that they want to deliver a
headset that will offer the experience
that they want to project for VR they
don't want to shortchange customers
perception of what the technology can do
and I think that's really smart and I
don't think this is going to change
Zuckerberg said that they've got plans
you know three five and ten years down
the road and VR for them as a social
platform sits within that five to ten
year range based on what he said during
the phone call so I think that also says
to me that look they're not in a huge
rush to turn this into a moneymaker
really quick you know it's the same
reasons why I think VR is going to be a
great platform in the future as long as
companies take the time to do it right
but it is something that you know down
the road they do want to turn into a
social platform that they it is
something they will want to make money
from and I think maybe that's the thing
that we're worrying about even though it
is further down the road is that
something that could be a negative and
the BOK euless experience no because I'm
in oculus was always in it to make money
themselves you know the fact that this
is a business is nothing new just that
the person who now owns that business
has changed I don't think the fact that
Facebook will leverage it in one venue
versus an
another is necessarily a bad thing those
will be able to coexist and one bit of
slightly bad news that we did get out of
this is that the minecraft creator notch
announced over Twitter immediately
following the news that he is pulling
support for the game that they doesn't
want to make oculus on VR on oculus VR
anymore well what do you think of that
is do you think other developers my
fellow student also want to pull their
games why do you think he did this uh
there might be another one or two that
follow I mean I think maybe he did that
because you know I guess in his words he
says that Facebook creeps him out so
yeah some people are worried about the
privacy issues on facebook and they
would rather not be associated with a
company that's dealing with controversy
but notch is such a reactionary person
and he has the freedom to do that you
know Mojang is based they've practically
gotten I can print money at this point
you know and we're going to do that it's
it's some publicity not that they really
need that but at the same time I don't
think it's indicative of what larger
companies are thinking I think Facebook
is going to be a good thing for oculus
in the long run and that won't only
inspire companies to take VR more
seriously and I think we're gonna hear a
lot more out of this in the coming year
and especially with more money like I
mean it they have some exciting things
that that oculus would be able to
accomplish with their new be our product
and lots and lots of money I'm gonna be
really excited for e3 and maybe you know
in the coming year to see what other
things we have coming out of this we
have to have Sony's Morpheus project I
mean this kind of says that VR is an
important thing and it is its own
industry that's worth putting lots and
lots of money into it I mean in that in
itself is just a positive thing yeah I
agree and I think it is also a viable
industry I'm excited to see where it
goes yeah and we'll be following this on
gamespot com stay tuned for all of your
breaking vr news needs